you
did you do your first game no my son was
sick this morning and the kids and I
were just getting ready for school and
we heard an enormous explosion or what
we thought might have been a truck that
came through my house we have a lot of
Mack trucks that drive through here and
there have been accidents and that's
immediately what I thought and then when
I came out to see is when I saw the
debris just coming right down the road
I worked there so I know the people in
the office and I wanted to check on my
neighbor because her end of her trailer
is right there and I just told my son
just call Naima 1 because I just kept
saying I know everybody in there I know
everybody in there and I just thought
for sure everybody was gone
as things calm down and as as things you
know cleared away I saw most of them
walking back across the street so they
got a warning from the maintenance guy
and who is a hero and he told him to
evacuate because they smelled the
propane and this is what just what I've
been hearing this is just this you know
what I've been told by a few employees
from leaf that were there and so they
were in the evacuated area that they
were supposed to be and he had gone back
down with the PAS the fireman and that's
when it exploded
you